el descontento social se presume a este
problema del aumento de los precios del
combustible o tiene raíces más profundas
o la respeta bueno es como como tú dices
hay varias motivos este tipo de crisis
nunca por una sola razón yo te diría que
en la superficie extra el tema económico
el tema del aumento de los precios
combustible de un combustible especial
que usa la mayoría población sus autos
pero en el fondo de la cuestión
encontramos cuestiones étnicas con las
minorías rusas con las minorías islámico
con las mayorías islámicas sobre todo
con aquellas que están vinculadas a
turquía y además un grave prueba
político entre las élites de un país que
ha sido gobernado en forma autoritaria
en los últimos 40 años
señor pedrosa podría explicarnos el
descontento que hay hacia el ex
presidente nursultán nasarbayev quien
fue despojado del consejo de seguridad
de kazajistán quien es este personaje
bueno más allá de una salva ayer es el
primero que viene presidente que tuvo el
país en su independencia de 990 se
avenía de la época de la unión soviética
recordemos que de las famosas ex
repúblicas soviéticas y se mantuvo en el
poder con mano de hierro durante más de
30 años o sea que en 2019 recién apenas
su renuncia y se mantuvo atrás del trono
pero siempre con él pueden sumarnos por
eso muchas de las protestas que digo y
en la en la capital del país son contra
él el actual presidente en parte no se
sabe si es un títere o si realmente
quiere tener un perfil propio de los
ciertos que eran parte de las consignas
y los pedidos es que se vaya
del poder del país ahora rusia ya ha
anunciado el envío de fuerzas de paz a
kazajistán que puede esperarse de la
respuesta de moscú
bueno para rusia esto no son buenas
noticias si hay pruebas en ucrania
aunque queda un poco más lejos en
afganistán los problemas siguen y eso
altera la región y efectivamente como
ustedes saben este es un país es el
noveno país más grande del mundo es un
país con fronteras con china y con rusia
rusia no no puede permitirse que este
país se desestabilice
yo creo que mandar tropas
digamos a kazajistán sería peor que el
problema que tienen ahora porque además
la mayoría kazaja tiene a su vez
problemas con las minorías de origen
étnico rusa que es casi el 20 por ciento
del país así que me parece a mí que
sería eso echar más gasolina al juego